其他人：交交易费之后
Others: After you pay the transaction fee
Tasha: 哦哦我知道
Tasha: Oh, I get it
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Okay
Tasha: 这对空气是有意义的
Tasha: This makes sense for air
Tasha: 嗯有意义
Tasha: Yeah, it makes sense
其他人：只要你花钱从我这买她的意义就产生了
Others: As long as you spend money to buy it from me, it creates value
Tasha: 两块钱一个
Tasha: Two yuan each
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
其他人：你要多少
Others: How many do you want?
其他人：就一个没问题
Others: Just one, no problem
Tasha: 要一个
Tasha: Just one
Tasha: 哈哈这也没问题
Tasha: Haha, that's fine
其他人：我跟你说
Others: Let me tell you
其他人：你现在是两块钱买
Others: Now you buy it for two yuan
其他人：随便转不找
Others: You can trade it freely
Tasha: 是的啊
Tasha: Yeah, right
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Tasha: 真的我草
Tasha: Really, damn
其他人：你这你这
Others: You, you
其他人：看你这涨到2块钱都涨不到吗
Others: Can't you see it won't even go up to two yuan?
Tasha: 哈哈哈不是
Tasha: Haha, no
Tasha: 万一没有一个人买怎么办
Tasha: What if no one buys it?
其他人：不是有好多
Others: But there are so many
其他人：他妈的不是
Others: Damn, isn't it?
Tasha: 这有什么
Tasha: What's the point
Tasha: 这有什么用
Tasha: What's the use
Tasha: 这有什么用啊
Tasha: What's the use of this
Tasha: 谁谁谁你给他们拍了个案例
Tasha: Who, who, did you take a case study for them
其他人：你给他们拍了个案例
Others: Did you take a case study for them
Tasha: 什么狗狗币
Tasha: What Dogecoin
Tasha: 像个像个宣传组织
Tasha: Like a promotional organization
其他人：都少倍啊50万倍
Others: Multiplied by how many times, 500,000 times
其他人：现在两块钱
Others: Now it's two yuan
其他人：你以后就100万北京一套别墅
Others: In the future, you'll have a million-dollar villa in Beijing.
Tasha: 那虚拟货币它最终有什么用呢
Tasha: So, what’s the ultimate use of virtual currencies?
Tasha: 比如说比特币
Tasha: Like Bitcoin, for example.
Tasha: 就当现实的钱来花吗
Tasha: Can you spend it like real money?
其他人：对啊嗯
Others: Yeah, exactly.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 那我如果花两块钱买一个
Tasha: So, if I spend 2 yuan to buy one,
Tasha: 我可以用一个亿购币
Tasha: can I use one billion coins
Tasha: 去买一瓶矿泉水吗
Tasha: to buy a bottle of mineral water?
其他人：可以啊只要矿泉水的拥有者
Others: Yes, as long as the owner of the mineral water
其他人：他认可了你的币
Others: recognizes your coins.
Tasha: 哦这样子
Tasha: Oh, I see.
其他人：一切都建立在一个互相共识的机制上
Others: Everything is based on a mutual consensus mechanism.
Tasha: 啊互相信任的啊
Tasha: Ah, mutual trust.
Tasha: 啊这样子
Tasha: Ah, got it.
Tasha: 懂了
Tasha: Understood.
Tasha: 我相信你
Tasha: I trust you.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
其他人：不是不是不是
Others: No, no, no.
其他人：另外一个女的
Others: It’s the other woman.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
其他人：我们是把那150个全藏了
Others: We hid all 150 of them.
Tasha: 那一
Tasha: That one.
Jake:不不不藏20个
Jake: No, no, hide 20 of them.
Tasha: 那150个一个币
Tasha: Those 150 coins, one coin.
其他人：你让他们非死非活只能找到20个币
Others: You make them find only 20 coins, dead or alive.
Tasha: 那比特币的话
Tasha: What about Bitcoin, then?
Tasha: 最后
Tasha: In the end...
Jake:不不不剩剩下的
Jake: No, no, the remaining ones.
Tasha: 呃一开始
Tasha: Uh, at the beginning...
Jake:他们要赚钱
Jake: They need to make money.
Jake:就是他们要打体赚钱
Jake: They need to work and earn money.
Tasha: 一开始是谁把他们炒起来捧红的呢
Tasha: Who was the one that made them popular in the first place?
Jake:所以150个差不多
Jake: So, 150 is about right.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Tasha: 那人家创始人跟我们这创始人不一样
Tasha: The founder there is different from our founder.
Tasha: 所以
Tasha: So...
其他人：比特币牛逼啊
Others: Bitcoin is awesome.
Tasha: 价值提升也不一样吧
Tasha: The value increase is different, right?
Tasha: 虚拟货币的人
Tasha: People in virtual currency...
Tasha: 虚拟货币可能以后用在元宇宙比较多
Tasha: Virtual currencies might be used more in the Metaverse in the future.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 就建立那套经济体系嘛
Tasha: To establish an economic system, right?
Tasha: 就用虚拟货币
Tasha: Using virtual currency.
Tasha: 所以以后币是不是越来越多
Tasha: So, will there be more and more currencies in the future?
Tasha: 开创一个伊沟小镇
Tasha: Creating a small town in Ego.
Tasha: 然后跟比特小镇建立联盟关系
Tasha: And then establishing an alliance with Bitcoin Town.
Tasha: 哈哈哈然后有一个统一的货币银行
Tasha: Haha, and then having a unified currency bank.
Tasha: 可以进行一个汇率转换
Tasha: That can do currency conversions.
其他人：没有没有
Others: No, no.
其他人： 这个
Others: This...
其他人：虚拟货币的核心目标就是把银行干掉
Others: The core goal of virtual currency is to get rid of banks.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
其他人：就是我们在网上买任何的币都是
Others: It's like, whenever we buy any currency online,
其他人：都是PUP的哦
Others: It's all PUP.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
其他人：所以中国给他干掉
Others: So China got rid of it.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha: 确实
Tasha: Indeed.
Tasha: 而且中国有好多实体经济
Tasha: Plus, China has a lot of real economy.
Tasha: 它就不允许元宇宙的出现
Tasha: It just doesn't allow the Metaverse to appear.
Tasha: 在大力打
Tasha: Cracking down hard.
Tasha: 大力打击
Tasha: 他就是想要实体经济嘛
Tasha: It just wants a real economy.
其他人：只要未来太发达了
Others: As long as the future is too advanced,
其他人：每个人能一秒钟瞬移过来
Others: Everyone can teleport in a second.
其他人：觉自由基就挺好
Others: Free radicals would be great.
其他人：现在网络上自由基太可怕了
Others: Now, online free radicals are too scary.
其他人：因为他这一般是先把币给的
Others: Because they usually give out currency first.
其他人：然后在银行卡打钱
Others: And then transfer money to the bank card.
Tasha: 不错很看好你们的项目
Tasha: Not bad, I really like your project.
Tasha: 我投两块钱
Tasha: I'll invest two bucks.
Tasha: 呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Tasha: Hehehehehe.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：过了
Others: Over.
Jake:你过了五年吧
Jake: You need five more years.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
其他人：过了三年你就买不到了
Others: In three years, you won't be able to buy it.
Tasha: 真的吗对
Tasha: Really, right?
Tasha: 好那我再加注5块
Tasha: Okay, I'll raise my stake by five bucks.
其他人：从第一个人找到第一个币
Others: The first person found the first coin.
其他人：那个就已经变了
Others: That already changed.
Tasha: 哦哦
Tasha: Oh, oh.
Jake:噢噢噢
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Tasha: 行那我投10块
Tasha: Okay, I'll bet 10 bucks.
其他人：没问题 10块钱买一个币啊
Others: No problem, 10 bucks for one coin.
Tasha: 又10块钱买一个了
Tasha: Another 10 bucks for one coin.
Tasha: 怎么坐地 起价
Tasha: Why raise the price?
Tasha: 不如两块钱一个啊可以
Tasha: How about 2 bucks for one? That works.
其他人：十块钱买5个币
Others: 10 bucks for 5 coins.
Jake:呵买游戏币
Jake: Haha, buying game coins.
Jake:当游戏
Jake: Just like a game.
Jake:那个那边走
Jake: That way.
Tasha: 到了
Tasha: We arrived.
其他人：差点赢了我差点赢了
Others: Almost won, I almost won.
其他人：走两下来
Others: Move two steps.
其他人：现在教你另外一个方式
Others: Now I'll teach you another way.
Jake:跑错了跑错了
Jake: Wrong way, wrong way.
其他人：二蓝色
Others: Two blues.
Jake:你干嘛呢
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake:要买东西啊
Jake: Want to buy something?
Tasha: 不要
Tasha: No.
Jake:踏进去了
Jake: Stepped in.
Tasha: 我的妈呀这么多快递
Tasha: Oh my gosh, so many packages.
Tasha: 彩票店呢
Tasha: Where's the lottery shop?
Jake:嗯彩票
Jake: Hmm, lottery.
Tasha: 彩票店吗
Tasha: Is it the lottery shop?
Jake:彩票店那边
Jake: The lottery shop is over there.
Jake:不着急不着急
Jake: No rush, no rush.
Jake:先取快递
Jake: Get the packages first.
Jake:在哪
Jake: Where is it?
Tasha: 先取快递
Tasha: Get the packages first.
其他人：然后找什么
Others: Then what?
Jake:然后再刮彩票
Jake: Then scratch the lottery tickets.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 我负责取我的
Tasha: I'll get mine.
Tasha: 你负责取群里面其他人的是吧
Tasha: You get the rest from the group, right?
Jake:呃不差不多了
Jake: Uh, almost done.
Jake:不是你你这边取20个
Jake: No, you need to get 20 here.
Jake:别人取4个
Jake: Others take 4.
Jake:那你取20个
Jake: You take 20.
Jake:我们取4个
Jake: We'll take 4.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake:我们一人取两个
Jake: Each of us will take two.
其他人：好你有20个
Others: Okay, you have 20.
Jake:他有20个
Jake: He has 20.
Jake:他是真牛逼
Jake: He's really awesome.
Tasha: 没有人替我娶啊
Tasha: No one is taking it for me.
Jake:我们我们
Jake: We, we...
Jake:就算替你取
Jake: Even if we take it for you...
Jake:我感觉昨天取不过来
Jake: I feel like yesterday we couldn't finish.
Jake:但是今天我们三个人要打车了
Jake: But today, the three of us need to take a cab.
Jake:我估计
Jake: I guess...
Tasha: 9707
Tasha: 9707.
Tasha: 我买的性价比都很高你知道吧
Tasha: I bought cost-effective ones, you know.
Tasha: 500块钱查到呗
Tasha: 500 yuan, check it out.
Tasha: 9707啊没查到
Tasha: 9707, didn't find it.
Tasha: 我们是去养老院啊
Tasha: We're going to the nursing home.
Jake:养啊养老院是什么
Jake: Nursing home? What's that?
Jake:这不是养老院
Jake: This isn't a nursing home.
Jake:养老院在哪
Jake: Where is the nursing home?
其他人：那个哦
Others: That one, oh.
Jake:那个就都都都在那吗
Jake: Is that where they all are?
其他人：一个没有啊
Others: Not a single one.
Jake:邻里驿站是那个
Jake: The community center is that one.
其他人：那个
Others: That one.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:这么回事
Jake: I see.
Jake:他他的这些都在
Jake: All his things are there.
Jake:你都在
Jake: You are there.
Tasha: 都在养老院
Tasha: All at the nursing home.
Jake:我靠再见我
Jake: Oh man, goodbye.
Tasha: 你你你你真的认识路吗
Tasha: Do you really know the way?
Tasha: 哎真的认识
Tasha: Hey, really know?
Tasha: 我真认识
Tasha: I really know.
Tasha: 你真的不会走错路吗
Tasha: You really won't get lost?
Tasha: 我绝对不会走错的
Tasha: I definitely won't get lost.
Jake:这这是真道啊
Jake: This, this is the right way.
Jake:一般都是在这先切磋一遍
Jake: Usually, we spar here first.
Jake:我怎么知道你都在
Jake: How would I know you were all here?
Jake:就是一个菜鸟都没有啊
Jake: Not even a single newbie, huh?
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Jake:一个菜鸟都没有
Jake: Not even a single newbie.
Jake:你看看还有多少电
Jake: Check how much battery is left.
Jake:还有多少
Jake: How much is left?
Tasha: 没看这呀
Tasha: Didn't check it.
Tasha: 还有多少呢
Tasha: How much is left?
Tasha: 35
Tasha: 35.
Tasha: thirty five
Tasha: Thirty-five.
Jake:怎么好
Jake: That's great.
Tasha: 这么好我给二年级小孩辅导哎
Tasha: It's so good, I'm tutoring second graders.
Jake:这么牛逼
Jake: That's awesome.
Jake:多少钱
Jake: How much?
Tasha: 200块钱一个小时
Tasha: 200 yuan an hour.
Jake:卧槽
Jake: Wow.
Jake:我应该我应该也会
Jake: I think I could do it too.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:二年级小孩我应该还能hold住的
Jake: I think I could handle second graders.
Tasha: 住是的呀
Tasha: Yeah, for sure.
其他人：初二我就hold不住吧
Others: Maybe not eighth graders though.
Jake:哈哈哈初中
Jake: Haha, middle school.
Tasha: 所以我
Tasha: So I...
Jake:为什么hold不住的
Jake: Why can't you handle it?
其他人：有点难
Others: It's a bit hard.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:小学小学
Jake: Elementary school, elementary school.
Jake:你教什么
Jake: What do you teach?
Jake:哈喽are you from Singapore
Jake: Hello, are you from Singapore?
Tasha: 教书本上的内容
Tasha: I teach the stuff from the textbooks.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:200块钱
Jake: 200 yuan.
Jake:他家长为什么这么有钱
Jake: Why are the parents so rich?
Tasha: 北京你搞不懂的
Tasha: You wouldn't get it, it's Beijing.
Tasha: 如果我是名师我就1,000块一个小时了
Tasha: If I were a famous teacher, I'd charge 1,000 yuan an hour.
Tasha: 哎哟
Tasha: Oh my.
Jake:咳
Jake: Cough.
Jake:小学二年级1,000块钱一小时
Jake: Second grade, 1,000 yuan an hour.
Tasha: 小学是2
Tasha: Elementary school is 2...
Tasha: 小学是200多
Tasha: Elementary school is over 200.
Tasha: 嗯初中就是四五百了
Tasha: Yeah, middle school is about four or five hundred.
Jake:四五百一小时
Jake: Four or five hundred an hour?
Tasha: 嗯高中名校
Tasha: Yeah, high school at a prestigious school.
Tasha: 一节课3,000
Tasha: One class is 3,000.
Jake:一节课是多久
Jake: How long is one class?
Jake:45分钟一个小时 3,000
Jake: 45 minutes to an hour, 3,000?
Tasha: 一个小时吧
Tasha: About an hour.
Tasha: 1.5个小时
Tasha: 1.5 hours.
Jake:一个人吧
Jake: One person?
Tasha: 是吧当然是一对一了
Tasha: Of course, one-on-one.
Jake:一对一
Jake: One-on-one.
Jake:一小时3,000
Jake: 3,000 per hour.
Tasha: 你要是名师OK
Tasha: If you're a famous teacher, okay.
Jake:名师是得多名师
Jake: How famous does the teacher need to be?
Tasha: 名师
Tasha: Famous.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Tasha: 我不是
Tasha: I'm not.
Tasha: 我也教不高
Tasha: I don't teach for that much.
Tasha: 教不了高中没有了解过那方面
Tasha: I can't teach high school, don't know much about it.
Jake:哦高中
Jake: Oh, high school.
Jake:太难了hold不住了
Jake: It's too hard, can't handle it.
Tasha: 我之前还看到一条消息说呃
Tasha: I saw this news before that said, um...
Tasha: 过年十天
Tasha: Over the New Year for ten days...
Tasha: 就是从大年初三到大年初十三
Tasha: From the third day of the New Year to the thirteenth...
Tasha: 还大年初五到到年初十五
Tasha: Or from the fifth to the fifteenth...
Tasha: 找一个清华北大的什么生
Tasha: Hire a student from Tsinghua or Peking University...
Tasha: 然后住家住十天是多少万
Tasha: And have them live with you for ten days for tens of thousands.
Tasha: 真的
Tasha: Really.
Tasha: 当时这条信息我看到
Tasha: When I saw this info, I thought...
Tasha: 只恨自己不是清华北大的
Tasha: I just wish I wasn't from Tsinghua or Peking.
Tasha: 不然就跑到人家家住10天
Tasha: Otherwise, I would go live with someone for ten days.
Jake:可以啊
Jake: Sounds good.
Tasha: 哦这呢
Tasha: Oh, here it is.
其他人：包食住2万10天
Others: All-inclusive, 20,000 for ten days.
Tasha: 包吃住2万10天
Tasha: All-inclusive, 20,000 for ten days.
Jake:2万10天
Jake: 20,000 for ten days.
Jake:那还一般
Jake: That's pretty average.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha.
Tasha: 还100 又不是让你24小时教
Tasha: Still 100, it's not like you're teaching 24 hours a day.
Tasha: 他一天就教几个小时吧
Tasha: He probably teaches for a few hours a day.
其他人：感觉一天就答答疑呗
Others: Seems like he just answers questions all day.
Tasha: 语数英哎
Tasha: Chinese, Math, English.
Tasha: 早上一门中午一门
Tasha: One subject in the morning, one at noon.
Tasha: 晚上一门不就学完了
Tasha: One in the evening, and you're done.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:对我们只能hold住小学跟大学
Jake: Yeah, we can only handle elementary and university.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈可以
Tasha: Hahahahahahahaha, right.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Tasha: 我也觉着
Tasha: I think so too.
Tasha: 目前我干的也是这两个业务
Tasha: Right now, I'm doing those two things as well.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha
Tasha: 这鸡怎么这么懒
Tasha: Why is this chicken so lazy?
Jake:懒
Jake: Lazy.
Tasha: 到现在才开始吃大米
Tasha: It's only starting to eat rice now?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 几点了都
Tasha: What time is it?
Jake:这这怎么就养老院了呢
Jake: How did this turn into a retirement home?
Tasha: 你好
Tasha: Hello.
Tasha: 9707
Tasha: 9707.
其他人：好咧 9707是吧
Others: Okay, 9707, right?
Jake:你是一个一个报啊还是一起报
Jake: Are you reporting one by one or all together?
其他人：您平常用啊
Others: As you usually do.
其他人：然后给您领一个20减5的优惠券然
Others: Then we'll get you a coupon for 20 minus 5.
Jake:咱不咱
Jake: We don't, we don't.
其他人：后扣20减5块
Others: Then deduct 20 minus 5.
Jake:咱不在这住
Jake: We don't live here.
Tasha: 嗯张
Tasha: Mm, Zhang.
其他人：请取走包裹
Others: Please pick up your package.
其他人：一人多件
Others: One person, many items.
其他人：请取走包裹
Others: Please pick up your package.
其他人：一人多件
Others: One person, many items.
其他人：取走包裹
Others: Pick up your package.
其他人：一人多件
Others: One person, many items.
Tasha: 他们刚刚没有菜鸟驿站的快递吗
Tasha: Didn't they have Cainiao Post packages earlier?
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
其他人：请取走包裹
Others: Please pick up your package.
其他人：一人多件
Others: One person, many items.
其他人：这个也是你的吧
Others: This is yours too, right?
其他人：没写愈合区
Others: Didn't write the healing area
其他人：写市场驿站
Others: Wrote market station
Tasha: 对是的嗯
Tasha: Yeah, that's right.
Jake:给点给点给点给点
Jake: Give some, give some, give some.
Jake:不给不给
Jake: No, not giving.
Jake:不给就不给了
Jake: Not giving then.
其他人：请取走包裹
Others: Please take the package.
其他人：一人多件
Others: One person, multiple items.
其他人：请取主操作一人多件
Others: Please handle one person, multiple items.
其他人： 稍等还有
Others: Hold on, there's more.
Tasha: 那等等还有
Tasha: Okay, hold on, there's more.
其他人：你都买的什么
Others: What did you buy?
Tasha: 你看嘛
Tasha: Look here.
Jake:你这个收拾你要收拾一天吧
Jake: You might take a whole day to sort this out.
Tasha: 所以我很着急
Tasha: That's why I'm in a hurry.
Jake:也对
Jake: True.
Tasha: 昨天晚上我就哭了
Tasha: I cried last night.
Tasha: 来不及了
Tasha: Couldn't make it in time.
其他人：为什么你的发的太慢了
Others: Why did yours ship so slowly?
其他人： 你买的太慢
Others: You bought too slowly.
Jake:取的太慢
Jake: Too slow to pick up.
Tasha: 买太多了
Tasha: Bought too much.
Tasha: 你看如果买只gelkat就直接解决了
Tasha: See, if you just bought Gelkat, it would've been solved directly.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 哎取快递在哪里
Tasha: Hey, where to pick up the package?
Tasha: 看看他们的12
Tasha: Look at their 12.
Tasha: 3
Tasha: 4
Tasha: 哦他们就4个啊
Tasha: Oh, they only have 4?
Jake:啊
Jake: Yeah.
其他人：你取完了
Others: You finished picking up?
Jake:你取完了
Jake: You done picking up?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Jake:没有我这还有两个呢
Jake: No, I still have two more.
Tasha: 这什么呀
Tasha: What's this?
Tasha: 海边奶茶店
Tasha: Beachside milk tea shop.
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What's this?
Tasha: 奶油泡泡盅
Tasha: Creamy bubble cup.
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What's this?
Tasha: 17代
Tasha: 17 generations
Jake:是什么
Jake: What is it?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Jake:这是你的吗
Jake: Is this yours?
Jake:是你的
Jake: It's yours.
Jake:不知道是真牛逼
Jake: No idea, really amazing.
Jake:放也放一哈
Jake: Put it down for a bit.
Tasha: 这什么
Tasha: What's this?
Jake:我觉得我不行啊
Jake: I don't think I can do it.
其他人：卧槽
Others: Whoa!
Jake:你你能行啊
Jake: You, you can do it?
Jake:我是不行的
Jake: I can't do it.
Jake:我们要分好几趟
Jake: We have to split into several trips.
Jake:打车我估计
Jake: Take a cab, I guess.
其他人：卧槽
Others: Whoa!
其他人：哈哈哈卧槽包子呀
Others: Hahaha, whoa, buns!
其他人：我草你是我姐
Others: Damn, you're my sister!
Jake:你你是我姐
Jake: You, you are my sister.
Jake:你想到你还能住一天啊
Jake: Did you think you could stay another day?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha!
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahaha!
其他人：哈哈
Others: Haha!
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha!
其他人：这他妈捡上去的
Others: This is so messed up!
Tasha: 哈哈退掉一下吧
Tasha: Haha, let's cancel it.
Tasha: 现在就退掉
Tasha: Cancel it now.
Jake:取没取完没关系
Jake: Doesn't matter if it's not finished.
Jake:你拿走你拿
Jake: You take it, you take it.
Jake:拿回宿舍去
Jake: Take it back to the dorm.
Jake:或者送我一点
Jake: Or give me some.
Tasha: 分你一点啊
Tasha: I'll share some with you.
Jake:分我一点啊
Jake: Share some with me.
Tasha: 行分你
Tasha: Sure, I'll share.
Tasha: 你到时候看中啥就直接拿走
Tasha: You just take whatever you like later.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 还有吗
Tasha: Is there more?
Jake:你自己的还没弄完呢
Jake: You haven't finished your own.
其他人：还有
Others: There's more.
Jake:来的不巧啊
Jake: Bad timing.
Tasha: 你等会把群里面的抱一下吧
Tasha: Can you share it in the group later?
Tasha: 我不好意思了
Tasha: I'm too shy to do it.
Jake:我来包我来包我来包
Jake: I'll share it, I'll share it, I'll share it.
Jake:你不放一会啊
Jake: Aren't you going to wait a bit?
Jake:啊没有
Jake: Oh, never mind.
Tasha: 上面还有两个哎
Tasha: There are two more on top.
Jake:哦不不不
Jake: Oh no, no, no.
Tasha: 哦哦
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Jake:就这俩然后姜维亚俩
Jake: Just these two, then the other two.
Tasha: 还有吗还有
Tasha: Are there more? Are there more?
Tasha: 还有几还有几
Tasha: How many more? How many more?
Tasha: 啊那就好
Tasha: Ah, that's good.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 这什么
Tasha: What's this?
Jake:这什么这什么点点
Jake: What's this? What's this? Click on it.
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What is this?
Tasha: 请取走包裹
Tasha: Please take the package away.
Jake:好我又有了啊
Jake: Alright, I've got it again.
Tasha: 啊不知道呀
Tasha: Ah, I don't know.
Tasha: 洋甘菊什么
Tasha: Chamomile, what?
Tasha: 这个是哎呦我天呐
Tasha: This is... Oh my gosh!
其他人：卧槽直接就拆了
Others: Whoa, just open it directly.
其他人：假的讲话吧
Others: Fake talk.
Tasha: 哎呦我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Tasha: 好丑呀
Tasha: This is so ugly.
Tasha: 你看
Tasha: Look.
Tasha: 这个买了之后清明节还能再用上啊
Tasha: After buying this, you can use it during Qingming Festival next year.
Tasha: 清明节下一年啊
Tasha: Qingming Festival next year.
其他人：你他妈这么早过清明节啊
Others: Are you celebrating Qingming Festival so early?
Tasha: 清明节下一年了吗
Tasha: Isn't Qingming Festival next year?
其他人：这么早过清明节
Others: Celebrating Qingming Festival so early.
Tasha: 你看这刚好用得上
Tasha: Look, it's just in time.
Jake:这么刚好啊
Jake: Just in time?
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 哈哈啊
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:这么刚好啊
Jake: Just in time?
Jake:呵呵还有啊
Jake: Haha, there's more?
Jake:132563和722563
Jake: 132563 and 722563.
其他人：我在路边
Others: I'm by the roadside.
Tasha: 真的吗那我们现在退了吧
Tasha: Really? Then let's return it now.
Jake:来再来两个
Jake: Come on, let's get two more.
Jake:我们规划一下吧
Jake: Let's make a plan.
Jake:想想办法
Jake: Think of something.
Tasha: 没想到我们吃完
Tasha: Didn't expect we'd finish eating.
Tasha: 后面已经堆了这么多人了
Tasha: And now there's a crowd behind us.
其他人：那不然是你啊
Others: Well, it's you, of course.
Jake:不是我们的啊
Jake: Not ours, though.
Jake:呃72呃 2563和132563 嗯
Jake: Uh 72, uh 2563 and 132563, hmm.
其他人：有 only you
Others: There's only you.
其他人：好吧
Others: Alright.
其他人：牛逼牛逼
Others: Impressive, impressive.
Jake:牛批一个抵5个
Jake: One boss can handle five.
Jake:咱还没取完呢咱
Jake: We haven't finished picking up yet.
Jake:咱太能买了咱
Jake: We sure can buy a lot.
Tasha: 你好过一下谢谢
Tasha: Excuse me, let me through, thanks.
Jake:好没了
Jake: Alright, that's it.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
其他人：你只有两个
Others: You only have two.
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
其他人：不是4个吗
Others: Weren't there four?
Jake:刚刚不是拿了两
Jake: Didn't we just get two?
Jake:个吗
Jake: Right?
Jake:是吧是嗯
Jake: Yeah, right, hmm.
Tasha: 是啊
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:吓我一跳
Jake: That scared me.
Jake:顺拿一张纸
Jake: Grab a piece of paper.
Tasha: 怎么办嘞
Tasha: What should we do?
Tasha: 怎么办啊
Jake:包走还是打退啊
Jake: Pack it up or return it?
Jake:包里走啊
Jake: Pack it up.
Tasha: 抱着走啊
Tasha: Carry it with us.
其他人：那我拿一下啊
Others: Let me grab it.
Jake:完了啊偷不到了
Jake: Done, can't steal it now.
Tasha: 偷
Tasha: Steal?
其他人：呵给我来一个
Others: Haha, give me one.
Tasha: 你东西这么多你都不忘记
Tasha: You have so much stuff, you never forget anything.
其他人：小偷不是偷
Others: A thief never forgets.
Jake:呵呵读书人
Jake: Haha, a scholar.
Tasha: 读书人拿东西叫偷吗
Tasha: When a scholar takes things, it's called stealing?
Jake:对读书人呢
Jake: Yeah, a scholar.
Tasha: 各取所需罢了
Tasha: Just take what you need.
Jake:这个能捡
Jake: This can be picked up.
Jake:这个能放进去吗
Jake: Can this be put inside?
Jake:这是要剪啊
Jake: This needs to be cut.
Jake:一会要系一下啊
Jake: Tie it up later.
Jake:啊呵呵呵
Jake: Ah hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈走吧
Tasha: Hahaha, let's go.
其他人：还挂个屁
Others: What's the point of hanging it?
Tasha: 给我给我给我
Tasha: Give it to me, give it to me.
Tasha: 还挂彩票吗
Tasha: Are you still hanging it up?
Jake:挂不了了
Jake: It can't be hung up anymore.
Tasha: 我跟你说这个寓意叫满载而归
Tasha: I'm telling you, this means returning fully loaded.
Tasha: 你现在去彩彩彩票店
Tasha: If you go to the lottery store now,
Tasha: 就可以刮100万回家
Tasha: you could scratch off a million.
Jake:那你刮不到一百万你在那边刮
Jake: If you can't scratch off a million, you stay there and scratch.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah?
Jake:啊你刮不到100万你就在那边刮
Jake: Yeah, if you can't scratch off a million, you stay there and scratch.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
其他人：你觉得那要有几百万我自己拿全款
Others: If I had millions, I'd keep the full amount.
其他人：没有的话你给我报销
Others: If not, you reimburse me.
其他人：有的话分你99万
Others: If yes, I'll give you 990,000.
其他人：我拿1万就行
Others: I'd be fine with 10,000.
Tasha: 今天星期几
Tasha: What day is it today?
Jake:星期天
Jake: Sunday.
Tasha: 今天星期天
Tasha: Today's Sunday.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 怎么了怎么了怎么了
Tasha: What's going on, what's going on, what's going on?
Tasha: 再扔一个上来
Tasha: Throw another one up here.
其他人：小事求之做
Others: It's a small matter, just do it.
其他人：卧槽你的室友
Others: Damn, your roommate.
其他人：他妈的一天偷了个好漂亮的打火机
Others: He stole a really beautiful lighter today.
Tasha: 打火机偷了一个好漂亮的
Tasha: Stole a really beautiful lighter.
Jake:哦这一段到底怎么处理
Jake: Oh, how do we handle this part?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈就是之前修硕就是打打嘴炮
Jake: Hahaha, before Shure was just talking big.
Jake:我们这把是真的哈哈哈
Jake: This time we are for real, hahaha.
Jake:你要不跟这个东西见面面去
Jake: Why don't you meet this thing?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Jake:这东西怎么弄
Jake: How do we handle this thing?
其他人：今天眼镜数量比较少
Others: There are fewer glasses today.
Tasha: 缺两把眼镜
Tasha: We're short two pairs of glasses.
Jake:喂
Jake: Hey.
Jake:这两把眼镜
Jake: These two pairs of glasses...
Jake:就比方说回去之后看到这就别人
Jake: Like, when you get back and see this, it's just other people...
其他人：我们就做那个shift detection
Others: We'll just do that shift detection.
其他人：是个黑颜色个
Others: It's a black signal.
其他人：个信号
Others: A signal.
其他人：以上都跟被被被窃人商量好的基本
Others: All of this was basically discussed with the person being monitored.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Jake:当然你说会不会有人自己看呢
Jake: Of course, you wonder if someone will watch it themselves...
Jake:啊哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
其他人：见怪不怪了嗯
Others: It's nothing surprising, huh.
Tasha: 哈我看你的快递都到脖子了
Tasha: Haha, I see your packages are up to your neck.
Tasha: 彼此彼此彼此
Tasha: Same here, same here.
Tasha: 还好三个人
Tasha: Thankfully, there are three of us.
Jake:嗯你要昨天让我们领年华
Jake: Hmm, if you had made us pick them up yesterday...
Jake:我觉得你回去日子不太好过
Jake: I think you'd have a hard time when you get back.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha
Tasha: 昨天也就12个
Tasha: There were only twelve yesterday.
Tasha: 就你都不知道我在学校
Tasha: You don't even know, at school...
Tasha: 我买烘焙东西买了80多个
Tasha: I bought over 80 baking items.
Tasha: 我一个人去玩的
Tasha: I went alone to get them.
Jake:你怎么去
Jake: How did you go?
其他人：那么小的学校
Others: Such a small school...
其他人：要买电瓶车哈哈哈
Others: You need an electric scooter, haha.
Tasha: 哈我知道
Tasha: Haha, I know.
Jake:你分几趟取的
Jake: How many trips did you make?
Tasha: 我一天去取20个
Tasha: I picked up 20 each day.
Jake:一天取20个
Jake: 20 each day?
Jake:80个发视频是吧
Jake: 80 packages, you're making a video, right?
Tasha: 呵呵呵
Tasha: Hehe
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehe
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Tasha: 我每天取快递拆快递就要一个小时
Tasha: Every day, it takes me an hour just to pick up and open packages.
Tasha: 我真受不了了
Tasha: I really can't take it anymore.
Tasha: 什么时候结工钱呀
Tasha: When are we getting paid?
Tasha: 老板
Tasha: Boss.
Tasha: 我听说他们都没有在活动前干活了
Tasha: I heard they all stopped working before the event.
其他人：嗯谁
Others: Hmm, who?
Jake:什么先先结账
Jake: What, pay first?
Jake:在干活是吧
Jake: Still working, right?
Tasha: 现结账我都把活干完了
Tasha: Pay now, I've finished all the work.
Tasha: 这里只限速5
Tasha: The speed limit here is 5.
Jake:我们没超速吧
Jake: We didn't speed, right?
Tasha: 我们
Tasha: We...
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 首先你要有四个轮子在谈这些
Tasha: First, you need to have four wheels to talk about these things.
Jake:哈不一定
Jake: Ha, not necessarily.
Jake:人应该能够
Jake: People should be able to...
Jake:人一人一小时能能跑5公里
Jake: A person can run 5 km in an hour.
其他人：肯定的
Others: Definitely.
Jake:对啊那人是能超速的
Jake: Yeah, so people can speed.
Jake:不需要四个轮子
Jake: No need for four wheels.
其他人：发一早上消息不搭理我
Others: Sent messages all morning, got ignored.
其他人：就问他为啥不搭理我
Others: Just ask why he ignored me.
其他人：刚看手机
Others: Just checked his phone.
其他人：谁信呢
Others: Who believes that?
Jake:谁信呢
Jake: Who believes that?
Tasha: 受不了了
Tasha: Can't take it anymore.
Tasha: 好晒啊
Tasha: So sunny.
其他人：拿不下了
Others: Can't carry it.
Tasha: 拿得下我说好晒
Tasha: I can carry it, I said it's sunny.
Tasha: 没事啊彩票店在哪
Tasha: It's fine, where's the lottery shop?
Jake:不是阴凉
Jake: Isn't it in the shade?
Jake:你不是晒吗
Jake: Aren't you sunny?
其他人：彩票店直接就在这
Others: The lottery shop is right here.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:这彩票店里面
Jake: This lottery shop...
Jake:既不晒还能赚钱
Jake: You won't get sunburned and might make money.
Jake:有可能赚钱
Jake: Possibly make money.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Jake:基本上亏钱
Jake: Mostly lose money.
Jake:你赚多少钱
Jake: How much did you win?
Jake:最多
Jake: At most?
Tasha: 一百块
Tasha: A hundred bucks.
Jake:多少100
Jake: How much, 100?
Jake:100
Jake: 100.
Jake:20块赚100块
Jake: Make 100 bucks from 20 bucks.
Tasha: 嗯二三十吧
Tasha: Hmm, around twenty or thirty.
Tasha: 这是我的最高纪录了
Tasha: That's my highest record.
Jake:嗯牛
Jake: Impressive.
Jake:你刮多少次
Jake: How many times did you scratch?
Tasha: 挂多少次
Tasha: How many times?
Jake:你总共刮多少次
Jake: How many times did you scratch in total?
Jake:有100次吗
Jake: Was it 100 times?
Tasha: 没有吧
Tasha: Probably not.
Jake:没有吧 50次 20次
Jake: No? Maybe 50 times? 20 times?
Tasha: 20次应该有了吧
Tasha: It should be around 20 times.
Jake:20次
Jake: 20 times.
Tasha: 出去玩只要走在街上
Tasha: Whenever I go out and walk on the street,
Tasha: 街上该溜子就没事干
Tasha: there's nothing to do for those hanging around.
Tasha: 就会进去刮一张
Tasha: So I just go in and scratch one.
Jake:哦就就这个就这个
Jake: Oh, just like this, just like this.
Tasha: 这不是有体彩吗
Tasha: Isn't there a lottery?
Tasha: 这不是体彩吗
Tasha: Isn't this the lottery?
Jake:是的是的就是这个
Jake: Yes, yes, that's it.
Jake:不好好上班
Jake: Not working properly.
Tasha: 这个里面吗
Tasha: Inside here?
Jake:你试试
Jake: Try it.
Tasha: 哦关门了
Tasha: Oh, it's closed.
Jake:走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:走吧省的10块钱
Jake: Let's go and save 10 bucks.
Jake:省的20块钱
Jake: Save 20 bucks.
Jake:亏他80块钱好吧
Jake: Lost 80 bucks, alright.
Jake:行不行
Jake: Okay?
Jake:好了好吧
Jake: Alright, fine.
Tasha: 好了眼镜提上去了
Tasha: Okay, the glasses are up.
Jake:你可能要充电
Jake: You might need to charge it.
Tasha: 充电但是
Tasha: Charge it but...
Jake:但是我们三个人
Jake: But the three of us...
Jake:都腾不出任何一只手给你充电
Jake: None of us have a free hand to charge it for you.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:人手还是太少了
Jake: We're still short-handed.
Tasha: 把脚别走路了
Tasha: Stop walking with your feet.
Jake:暂时用一下也行
Jake: You can use it temporarily.
Tasha: 还有一个行业
Tasha: There's another industry.
Tasha: 你知道KFC
Tasha: Do you know KFC?
Tasha: 代吃吗这个行业KFC代吃
Tasha: Is there an industry for eating on behalf of others, like KFC eating on behalf?
Jake:卧槽这什么东西
Jake: What the heck is this?
Jake:没听说过
Jake: Never heard of it.
Jake:讲讲没听说过
Jake: Explain, I've never heard of it.
Tasha: 没听说过
Tasha: Never heard of it.
Tasha: 你把肯德基吃了啊
Tasha: You eat the KFC, right?
其他人：KFC把肯德基吃了
Others: Eat the KFC.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:然后呢
Jake: Then what?
Tasha: 把玩具寄给别人就赚钱
Tasha: You send the toys to others and make money.
Tasha: 这不知道
Tasha: I don't know about this.
其他人：这是稳定工艺吗
Others: Is this a stable craft?
Tasha: 稳定工艺啊
Tasha: Stable craft, yeah.
Tasha: 哎呦我靠哎呦我靠
Tasha: Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Tasha: 完了完了
Tasha: It's over, it's over.
Jake:重开吧
Jake: Let's restart.
Tasha: 资源重新分配
Tasha: Reallocate resources.
Jake:重开给我
Jake: Restart for me.
其他人：正好你充电吧
Others: You can charge meanwhile.
Jake:哎可以
Jake: Oh, that's good.
Jake:你把那拿走充电
Jake: You take that and charge it.
Jake:快快
Jake: Quickly, quickly.
Tasha: 累倒了
Tasha: Exhausted.
其他人：是每天都来还是没做
Others: Does he come every day or not at all?
Tasha: 每次他有活动
Tasha: Every time he has an event.
其他人：得等他活动呗
Others: So, we wait for his events, right?
Tasha: 他活动不是很快吗
Tasha: Aren't his events frequent?
Tasha: 每个节日都有活动
Tasha: There's an event every holiday.
其他人：一天可能吃不了多少
Others: He can't eat much in a day.
Tasha: 你想吃多少就吃多少
Tasha: You can eat as much as you want.
其他人：那我就买不吃不就行了
Others: Then I just buy it and not eat it.
Tasha: 你怎么可能买光买完就不吃呢
Tasha: How can you buy everything and not eat it?
Jake:会有可能的呀
Jake: It's possible.
Tasha: 他是
Tasha: He's...
Tasha: 几开心了
Tasha: So happy.
Tasha: （歌词）五十六个民族五十六朵花
Tasha: (Lyrics) Fifty-six ethnic groups, fifty-six flowers.
Tasha: （歌词）五十六个中华民族是一家
Tasha: (Lyrics) Fifty-six Chinese ethnic groups are one family.
Jake:好像不太对
Jake: Seems not quite right.
Jake:你是回族
Jake: You are Hui, right?
Tasha: 真的吗那你加多少分
Tasha: Really? Then how many extra points do you get?
Jake:那你吃
Jake:那你怎么吃
Jake:那你什么回族
Jake: What kind of Hui are you?
其他人：  身份证回族
Others: Hui on the ID card.
Jake:加多少分
Jake: How many extra points?
其他人：就就正好加了5分
Others: Just exactly 5 points.
Tasha: 这还不好啊
Tasha: Isn't that good?
其他人：有什么屌用
Others: What's the use of it?
Tasha: 拼死拼活的
Tasha: Fighting so hard.
Tasha: 我们小高考都加不了5分
Tasha: We can't even get 5 points in the minor exams.
Tasha: 得4科考a
Tasha: Need to get all A's in 4 subjects.
Jake:为什么高考不加分
Jake: Why don't you get extra points for the college entrance exam?
其他人：我们必须要户口所在地是少数民族集聚区
Others: We must be in a minority-concentrated area according to our household registration.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, I see.
Tasha: 噢
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: saw dessine唉
Tasha: saw dessine, sigh.
Jake:那你是哪里啊你是
Jake: Where are you from?
Tasha: 唉呦唉呦
Tasha: Oh dear, oh dear.
Jake:哎哎呦哎呦
Jake: Oh dear, oh dear.
其他人：我爸是回族是因为他高考能加5分
Others: My dad is Hui because he got 5 extra points in the college entrance exam.
Tasha: 哎你能分开吗
Tasha: Hey, can you separate?
Jake:我分我分
Jake: I can, I can.
Jake:不哎我现在能分开了
Jake: No, wait, I can separate now.
Jake:但是还是可以有一只手
Jake: But I can still use one hand.
其他人：我爸就我爸就
Others: My dad just, my dad just...
其他人：不吃啊啊
Others: Doesn't eat, ah, ah.
其他人：你爸也吃啊
Others: Your dad eats too.
其他人：那从我奶奶开始吃   哦
Others: It started with my grandma. Oh.
Jake:那你有个好
Jake: Then you have a good...
Tasha: 桀骜不驯的奶奶
Tasha: A rebellious grandma.
Jake:对你有个好奶奶
Jake: Yeah, you have a good grandma.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 不吃的话你可能要比现在更瘦了
Jake:哈哈哈哈有点搞笑
Jake: Hahaha, this is kind of funny.
Tasha: 为什么要卡掉
Tasha: Why would you cut it out?
Tasha: 搞笑啊
Tasha: It's funny!
其他人：全全国全球公司人还是挺多的
Others: There are still quite a lot of people in the company nationwide and globally.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 要不这段全程别播了
Tasha: How about we don't air this part?
Jake:有点搞笑
Jake: It's kind of funny.
Tasha: 柳絮纷飞
Tasha: Willow catkins flying.
Jake:到时候我觉得最后要不还是就是就是
Jake: By then, I think, in the end, should we just...
Tasha: 澄清一下
Tasha: Clarify a bit.
Jake:哔哔哔哈哈哈
Jake: Beep beep beep, hahaha.
Jake:这个数据线当然有点牛逼哈哈哈哈
Jake: This data cable is pretty awesome, hahaha.
Jake:哔哔率97%哈
Jake: Beep rate is 97%, huh.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Jake:哔哔哔哔哔哔
Jake: Beep beep beep beep beep beep.
其他人：我是回族我哔哔
Others: I'm Hui and I beep.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake:我我吃哔哔
Jake: I, I eat beep.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:给一个
Jake: Give me one.
Jake:你要帮忙吗
Jake: Do you need help?
Tasha: 嗯这是我什么时候掉下去的
Tasha: Hmm, when did I fall down?
Tasha: 哦重新分配那会
Tasha: Oh, during the redistribution.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:羊肉也蛮好吃的是吧
Jake: Lamb is also pretty tasty, right?
Jake:牛羊肉
Jake: Beef and lamb.
Jake:你们有你们海港比爹回民有基础啊
Jake: You guys, your harbor has a foundation with the Hui people, right?
Jake:还有哎呦我操
Jake: And oh my god.
其他人：我奶奶的兄弟好像
Others: My grandma's brother seems...
Jake:哦就是还要去那叫什么
Jake: Oh, so you still go to that place called...
Jake:不去那种寺是吧
Jake: You don't go to that kind of mosque, right?
Jake:叫回民寺
Jake: Called Hui mosque.
Jake:叫叫什么
Jake: Called what?
Jake:叫回民清真寺
Jake: Called Hui Islamic mosque.
其他人：清真寺
Others: Mosque.
其他人： 但我认识那种西北的那种全是
Others: But I know that kind in the northwest, they are all...
其他人：但是他们虽然还是结婚有影响
Others: But even though they still, marriage is still influenced...
其他人：但是大部分也喝酒抽烟
Others: But most of them also drink and smoke.
Tasha: 结婚
Tasha: Getting married.
Jake:结婚干嘛
Jake: What's the point of getting married?
Jake:结婚结婚
Jake: Getting married, getting married.
其他人：回民其实必须得跟回民结婚
Others: Hui people actually have to marry other Hui people.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 好像不允许跟外族通婚
Tasha: It seems like marrying outside the ethnicity is not allowed.
Jake:oh
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 私自通婚
Tasha: Marrying secretly.
其他人：跟我单挑
Others: Duel with me.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This.
Tasha: 你真的认识路吗杨sir
Tasha: Do you really know the way, Jake?
Jake:认识一半嘛
Jake: I know half of it.
Jake:这不过半了嘛
Jake: Isn't this more than half?
Jake:哈哈这不过半了嘛
Jake: Haha, isn't this more than half?
Jake:是吧认识一大半
Jake: Right, I know most of it.
Tasha: 跟你们在一起被迫学会了识路
Tasha: Being with you guys, I was forced to learn to find my way.
其他人：没办法我10,000%的路数
Others: No choice, I know 10,000% of the routes.
Jake:我大概50%
Jake: I know about 50%.
其他人：我就之之前啊有一次
Others: Once, I had an appointment with my teacher for a meal.
其他人：嗯我约我的一个老师去吃饭
Others: Hmm, I had no idea.
其他人：哎我不晓得
Others: He was at school, and I just took the bus.
其他人：他在学校我直接坐公交车走哦
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:我们我们回头测一下每个人掉包率
Jake: Let's test everyone's swap rate later.
Tasha: 掉包率啊
Tasha: Swap rate?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈掉包率
Jake: Hahahaha, swap rate.
Tasha: 添包
Tasha: Adding bags.
Jake:掉包率然后呢
Jake: Swap rate, and then...
其他人：嗯我坐了公交车坐了十分钟
Others: Hmm, I took the bus for ten minutes.
其他人：嗯一共就20分钟
Others: It was a twenty-minute ride in total.
其他人：嗯坐了十分钟
Others: Hmm, I rode for ten minutes.
其他人：老师问你个厨房啊
Others: The teacher asked you, in the kitchen?
其他人：我说我操问你在公交车上
Others: I said, damn, asking you on the bus.
其他人：他说那我挂了你骂
Others: He said, then I'll hang up, you scold me.
Tasha: 做反了
Tasha: Did it wrong.
其他人：嗯然后他说那还准备一起打车呢
Others: Hmm, then he said, let's just take a taxi together.
其他人：哦我说那我在那等你吧
Others: Oh, I said, I'll wait for you there.
其他人：打车好还是骑车好
Others: Is it better to take a taxi or ride a bike?
其他人：我说我帮你搜一下
Others: I said, let me check for you.
其他人：嗯我他妈一速吊了
Other people: Hmm, damn, I was the fastest.
其他人：老子怎么时间从20分钟到30分钟啊
Other people: How did my time go from 20 minutes to 30 minutes?
其他人：哈哈哈
Other people: Hahaha
其他人：然后我就跟他说你在学校门口等我吧
Other people: Then I told him to wait for me at the school gate.
其他人：我马上打车来刷哦
Other people: I'll take a cab and come right over.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Jake:车坐反了
Jake: You took the bus in the wrong direction.
Tasha: 经常坐公交车坐反
Tasha: I often take the bus in the wrong direction.
Jake:你也你你你你也坐反
Jake: You too, you too?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:你是我姐
Jake: You're like my sister.
Jake:你也坐反
Jake: You also took it the wrong way.
Tasha: 那我没做饭过
Tasha: But I didn't cook.
Tasha: 我做饭那一次是我自己一个人
Tasha: The one time I cooked, I was alone.
Tasha: 10岁去南京玩
Tasha: I went to Nanjing when I was 10.
Jake:嗯嗯
Jake: Uh-huh.
Jake:你实在挺猛啊
Jake: You're really something.
Tasha: 坐反了我那天一直坐到晚上
Tasha: I took the wrong bus and rode it all day.
Jake:哈哈哈不是你你你坐反了
Jake: Hahaha, no way, you took it the wrong way?
Tasha: 坐到了大山里
Tasha: I ended up in the mountains.
Tasha: 你知道吗
Tasha: You know?
Tasha: 坐那个公交车
Tasha: I was on that bus.
Jake:坐山东去
Jake: You went to Shandong?
Tasha: 当时好像正好是什么会
Tasha: There was some event at the time.
Tasha: 什么北京举办什么会
Tasha: Some event held in Beijing.
Tasha: 好多志愿者过去问他怎么回去
Tasha: Lots of volunteers came and asked how to get back.
Tasha: 然后他们把我带回去了
Tasha: Then they took me back.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha: 嗯 10岁举办什么会我忘了
Tasha: Yeah, I forgot what the event was when I was 10.
Jake:你你你 10岁你去南京
Jake: You, you, you went to Nanjing when you were 10?
Tasha: 奥林匹克南京
Tasha: The Olympics in Nanjing.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:然后北京办一个什么会
Jake: And Beijing held some event?
Tasha: 南京办了什么会
Tasha: Nanjing held some event.
Tasha: 我一直坐反了
Tasha: I kept taking the wrong bus.
Tasha: 坐到大山里面
Tasha: Ended up deep in the mountains.
Jake:青奥会青奥会青奥会青奥会志愿者
Jake: The Youth Olympics, Youth Olympics, Youth Olympics, Youth Olympics volunteers.
Tasha: 坐到大山里
Tasha: Ended up in the mountains.
Tasha: 然后他们最后志愿者
Tasha: Then finally the volunteers...
Tasha: 在那个公交站台的时候
Tasha: At the bus station took me back.
Tasha: 然后就把我接回去了
Tasha: Then they took me back.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:搞笑哎
Jake: That's funny.
Jake:不行我再看看我的手机
Jake: No, I need to check my phone again.
Jake:不然马上又给我留人打电话
Jake: Otherwise, they'll call me right away.
Jake:又把我骂一顿
Jake: And scold me again.
Jake:没有他因为他昨天
Jake: No, because yesterday...
Jake:昨天拿东西的时候没接他电话
Jake: Yesterday, when I was picking up stuff, I didn't answer his call.
Jake:回头就把我骂一顿
Jake: So he scolded me later.
其他人： 她
Others: She.
Jake:啊我姐
Jake: Ah, my sister.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 不死留根
Tasha: Never give up.
Tasha: 哇我们真顽强
Tasha: Wow, we're really tough.
Tasha: 我们居然一路走下来了
Tasha: We actually made it all the way here.
Jake:牛逼
Jake: Awesome.
Tasha: 杨光把剩下钱能不能分摊给咱俩
Tasha: Can Yang Guang share the remaining money with us?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
其他人：牛逼
Others: Awesome.
Tasha: 要把这个铲掉吗
Tasha: Should we remove this?
Jake:他要技术不怎么样的话
Jake: If his skills aren't good...
Jake:屌爆了
Jake: It will be a disaster.
Tasha: 你会开铲车吗
Tasha: Can you drive a bulldozer?
Tasha: 我会开
Tasha: I can.
Jake:我不会我去
Jake: I can't, oh man.
Tasha: 哈哈哈我家有
Tasha: Haha, we have one at home.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake:你真是
Jake: You're something else.
Tasha: 我家有没有
Tasha: Do we have one at home?
Tasha: 我家真有
Tasha: We really do.
Tasha: 就在我家门口停着
Tasha: It's parked right outside my house.
Jake:哈哈哪天
Jake: Haha, when...
Tasha: 每天都能开
Tasha: I can drive it every day.
Jake:哪天去你家玩
Jake: Someday, let's visit your place.
Tasha: 好呀我家还有船准备去
Tasha: Sure, we also have a boat, let's get ready to go.
Jake:组组队去乖乖
Jake: Let's form a team, wow.
Jake:你家还有船啊
Jake: You have a boat too?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 大运河边上嘛
Tasha: By the Grand Canal.
Tasha: 靠船生活
Tasha: Living off the boats.
Jake:你家是什么
Jake: What does your family do?
Tasha: 家是什么
Tasha: What does the family do?
Tasha: 是是我们家靠船起家的
Tasha: Yes, our family made a living from boats.
Jake:不是不是
Jake: No, no.
Jake:你刚是开什么叉车
Jake: What kind of forklift were you driving?
Jake:开开什么车
Jake: What kind of vehicle?
Tasha: 开叉车铲车呀
Tasha: Forklift and loader.
Jake:铲车就就这种是吧
Jake: Loader, like this kind, right?
Jake:啊挖掘机
Jake: Oh, an excavator.
Tasha: 我家门口就有
Tasha: We have one right at our door.
Tasha: 然后你猜我们家干什么生意的
Tasha: Then guess what business my family is in.
Jake:运
Jake: Transport.
Jake:你家卖盐
Jake: Your family sells salt.
Tasha: 就卖这个沙子的
Tasha: We sell sand.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 然后那个船就是用来运沙的
Tasha: And the boats are used to transport sand.
Jake:沙子怎么卖
Jake: How do you sell the sand?
Jake:这沙子怎么卖
Jake: How do you sell this sand?
Jake:沙子你怎么做啊
Jake: How do you process the sand?
其他人：你自己处理的吗
Others: Do you handle it yourself?
Tasha: 沙子就是从用船运过来的
Tasha: The sand is transported by boat.
Tasha: 好像就是把
Tasha: It's like...
其他人：你运过来再把它卖走
Others: You bring it over and then sell it.
其他人：你是中间商
Others: You're a middleman.
Tasha: 对啊我爸说只要只要差价5毛钱一船
Tasha: Yeah, my dad says we just need a 50-cent profit per boat.
Jake:你处理什么呀
Jake: What do you handle?
Tasha: 一船沙子就能卖20万
Tasha: A boat of sand can be sold for 200,000 yuan.
Tasha: 哈哈就这5毛钱
Tasha: Haha, just for that 50 cents.
Jake:就是你们倒卖是吧
Jake: So you guys are reselling, right?
Jake:还是什么
Jake: Or what?
Tasha: 就是倒卖吗对啊
Tasha: Yes, just reselling.
Jake:呵呵呵可以
Jake: Haha, that's good.
Tasha: 5毛钱差价就能赚20万
Tasha: A 50-cent profit can earn 200,000 yuan.
其他人：现在有多少人差价
Others: How many people do this now?
Tasha: 不知道我爸说生意没以前好做了
Tasha: I don't know, my dad says business isn't as good as it used to be.
Tasha: 以前一个月卖一船
Tasha: We used to sell one boat a month.
Tasha: 现在好像不知道几个月卖一船
Tasha: Now it seems like we sell one boat every few months.
Jake:对以前是做生意
Jake: Yeah, it used to be easier to do business.
Tasha: 以前以前生意就是房地产好的那会
Tasha: Back when the real estate business was booming...
Jake:哦哦哦建大楼
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, building high-rises.
Tasha: 一个月卖一船啊
Tasha: We could sell a shipload a month.
Jake:现在没大楼建了
Jake: Now there's no more high-rises being built.
Tasha: 然后好几辆船停在我们家旁边
Tasha: Then several ships would dock next to our house.
Jake:然后巴闭吧
Jake: That was impressive, huh?
Tasha: 然后每天都在铲哈哈
Tasha: And we would be shoveling every day, haha.
Jake:呵呵发币吧
Jake: Haha, like mining money.
Tasha: 偶尔我也会帮忙铲铲
Tasha: Sometimes I would help with the shoveling too.
Jake:偶尔开开挖机
Jake: And occasionally operate the excavator.
Jake:是吧对
Jake: Right?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Tasha: 会开开
Tasha: I can operate it.
Jake:这个要驾照啊
Jake: You need a license for that, right?
Tasha: 这个这个
Tasha: This, this...
Tasha: 自己在自己家开不要驾照吧
Tasha: If you're operating it at home, you don't need a license, right?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 就是自己家有一个运沙场
Tasha: We have a sand transport yard at home.
Jake:也不会上路啊
Jake: It wouldn't be on the road anyway.
Jake:这个应该不会上路吧
Jake: It shouldn't be on the road, right?
其他人：这里还有一个运沙场
Others: There's another sand transport yard here.
Tasha: 就是运沙子的地方呀
Tasha: Yeah, it's for transporting sand.
Jake:这这个
Jake: This, this...
Jake:你你家多大呀
Jake: How big is your place?
Tasha: 我家多大
Tasha: How big is my place?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: You don't know?
Jake:好无边无际啊
Jake: It's boundless.
Tasha: 没有人的区
Tasha: There's no one around.
Tasha: 都给我们家堆沙子了
Tasha: It's all sand piles at our place.
Jake:哦这么回事那
Jake: Oh, that's how it is.
Jake:那是真的我看
Jake: That’s true, I see.
Tasha: 在海边能有几个人住
Tasha: How many people can live by the sea?
Tasha: 不是海边
Tasha: It's not by the sea.
Tasha: 湖边河边
Tasha: It's by a lake or a river.
其他人：在哪里啊
Others: Where is it?
Tasha: 大运河边
Tasha: By the Grand Canal.
Jake:京杭大运河
Jake: The Beijing-Hangzhou Grand Canal.
Jake:这个我懂
Jake: I get it.
其他人：什么城市
Others: What city?
Jake:扬州啊
Jake: Yangzhou.
其他人：扬州
Others: Yangzhou.
Jake:没有江苏人这种东西
Jake: There's no such thing as a Jiangsu person.
Tasha: 你们家经商吗
Tasha: Does your family do business?
Jake:我我们家不经商
Jake: No, my family doesn't do business.
Tasha: 你们家干嘛的
Tasha: What does your family do?
Jake:我们家
Jake: My family...
Tasha: 怪不得怪不得
Tasha: No wonder, no wonder.
Tasha: 因为我们家都经商
Tasha: Because my family is all in business.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:我们家干嘛的
Jake: What does your family do?
Tasha: 你们家干嘛的
Tasha: What does your family do?
Jake:我们家坐办公室的
Jake: My family works in offices.
Tasha: 坐办公室的
Tasha: In offices?
Tasha: 全部都是
Tasha: All of them?
Jake:嗯全坐办公室的
Jake: Yeah, all in offices.
Tasha: 嗯真好
Tasha: That's nice.
Jake:这不好玩没
Jake: It's not fun at all.
Jake:没有叉车要
Jake: No forklifts needed.
Tasha: 这有什么好玩的
Tasha: What's fun about that?
Tasha: 要要什么好啊
Tasha: What's so good about that?
Jake:没叉车座啊
Jake: No forklift seats.
Jake:没有叉车座
Tasha: 你要查车座干嘛
Tasha: Why do you need forklift seats?
Jake:那不是牛逼啊
Jake: Isn't that cool?
Shure: 呦你们回来了啊
Shure: Oh, you guys are back?
Jake:有电吗你们啊
Jake: Do you guys have electricity?
Jake:你们有电吗
Jake: Do you have power?
Shure: 你没电了啊
Shure: You don't have power?
Shure: 你这么用心的摸鱼居然没被发现天
Shure: You worked so hard slacking off and didn't get caught?
Shure: 杨老板我在这兢兢业业的收拾院子
Shure: Jake, I'm here diligently cleaning the yard.
Jake:哎呀没关系
Jake: Ah, it's fine.
Shure: 就在这坐着摸鱼
Shure: Just sitting here slacking off.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:快递回来了吗
Alice: Has the package arrived?
Jake:快递回来了
Jake: The package has arrived.
Alice:太累了
Alice: So tired.
Alice:是不是我的啥
Alice: Is it my stuff?
Jake:这是什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Alice:小雏菊
Alice: Little Daisy
Shure: daisy
Shure: Daisy
Katrina: 呵呵呵高级屌丝
Katrina: Haha, high-level loser
Jake:什么5块钱啊
Jake: What's this about 5 bucks?
Tasha: 冰红茶哦
Tasha: Iced tea
其他人：猕猴桃都5块了哦
Others: Even kiwi is 5 bucks now
Shure: 就是这个大瓶
Shure: It's this big bottle
Shure: 就是原来他500毫升是卖3块钱
Shure: It used to be 3 bucks for 500ml
Tasha: 4块
Tasha: 4 bucks
Shure: 然后一升的卖4块钱
Shure: And now, 1 liter is 4 bucks
Shure: 然后所以
Shure: So
Shure: 大家称这个4块钱这个为屌丝饮料
Shure: Everyone calls this 4-buck drink a loser drink
Jake:哦 4块钱还屌丝
Jake: Oh, 4 bucks and it's still a loser drink
Tasha: 完了完了
Tasha: Oh no, oh no
Tasha: 把草莓全漏进去了这
Tasha: I spilled all the strawberries in
Tasha: 这能帮我拿一下吗
Tasha: Can you help me with this?
Tasha: 这这堆太高了
Tasha: This pile is too high
Tasha: 没有吧
Tasha: No way
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Ugh
Tasha: 想偷个小饮料喝喝啊帮我也买一个
Tasha: Trying to sneak a drink, huh? Get me one too
Lucia: 啊帮我也拿一个我刚刚想跟你说可以帮我拿一个养乐多吗
Lucia: Oh, get me one too. I was just about to ask if you could get me a Yakult
Lucia: 这层东西有点多
Lucia: There's too much stuff here
Lucia: 我昨天甚至还拿上去了一点
Lucia: I even took some up yesterday
Lucia: 但是还是挺多的
Lucia: But there's still a lot
Lucia: 刚刚不小心偷饮料的时候
Lucia: Just now, while trying to sneak a drink
Lucia:  把草莓打翻了谢谢
Lucia: I spilled the strawberries, thank you
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Lucia: 能放下吗
Lucia: Can you put it down?
Lucia: 咱这剩下几天的水果都最后没有着落
Lucia: Now we have no place for the fruits for the next few days
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yeah
Tasha: 还剩下几天
Tasha: How many days left?
Lucia: 今天明天
Lucia: Today and tomorrow
Tasha: 不就剩下两天
Tasha: So only two days left
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Jake:人均没电
Jake: Everyone's out of power
Jake:挺好
Jake: That's good
Lucia: 啊没电了吗
Lucia: Oh, no more power?
Jake:没了
Jake: None
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay
Lucia: 这样没电了我要再开一个吗
Lucia: So, no power, should I start another one?
Jake:开一个开呀开
Jake: Open one, open.
Jake:谢谢开什么
Jake: Thank you, open what?
Lucia: 开一个心吧开
Lucia: Open your heart, open.
Jake:开好嗯
Jake: Open it, okay.
Tasha: 啊热死了
Tasha: Ah, it's so hot.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 拆快递
Tasha: Unbox the package.
Jake:徒手拆快递表演
Jake: Unbox the package with bare hands performance.
Jake:一个徒口拆快递
Jake: Unbox the package with bare mouth.
Tasha: 拿剪刀了我
Tasha: I'm getting the scissors.
Jake:哎你的那个线呢
Jake: Hey, where's your cable?
Jake:你自己的线你知道在哪吗
Jake: Do you know where your cable is?
Tasha: 我的线在我的包里
Tasha: My cable is in my bag.
Tasha: 我的包在我的包里
Tasha: My bag is in my bag.
Jake:你的包里
Jake: In your bag.
Tasha: 楼上呢
Tasha: Upstairs.
Jake:好那你去拿吧
Jake: Okay, then go get it.
Tasha: 充电宝呢
Tasha: Where's the power bank?
Jake:你先去哪
Jake: Where are you going first?
Tasha: （歌词）五十六个民族五十六朵花
Tasha: (Singing) Fifty-six ethnic groups, fifty-six flowers.
Jake:修欢修数修卡
Jake: Shure Huan, Shure Shu, Shure Ka.
Jake:哈哈哈我看啊看啊
Jake: Hahaha, I'm watching, watching.
Tasha: 哦我说我的剪刀呢
Tasha: Oh, I was wondering where my scissors are.
Jake:这这什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Lucia: 啊这个是你的剪刀
Lucia: Ah, these are your scissors.
Tasha: 对这是我行李箱里带的
Tasha: Yes, I brought them in my suitcase.
Lucia: 哦谢谢
Lucia: Oh, thanks.
Lucia: 我刚才一直在拿他剪那个墙纸
Lucia: I was just using them to cut the wallpaper.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 你先用好了
Lucia: You use them first.
Lucia:  我应该啊啊
Lucia: I should...
Tasha: 啊哎呦我靠
Tasha: Ah, ouch, damn.
Jake:可以是吧
Jake: Is it okay?
Shure: 是吧这个
Shure: Is it this?
Shure: 我绞尽脑汁想了半天
Shure: I racked my brain thinking for a long time.
Jake:这花多少钱
Jake: How much does this cost?
Shure: 这是我自己写的
Shure: I wrote it myself.
Jake:哦不值钱是吧
Jake: Oh, it's not worth much, right?
Shure: 呵呵
Shure: Hehe.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 更值钱了吧不应该
Shure: It should be more valuable, right?
Jake:好好更值钱
Jake: Yes, yes, more valuable.
Jake:值钱值钱
Jake: More valuable, more valuable.
Shure: 高霞红
Shure: Gaoxia Hong
Tasha: （歌词）56个中华民族是一家
Tasha: (Lyrics) 56 ethnic groups, one family
Jake:你知道他叫什么吗
Jake: Do you know what his name is?
Jake:英文名
Jake: His English name?
Shure: 他吗
Shure: His?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:他叫他叫古希腊
Jake: His name is Ancient Greece.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Jake:他叫古希腊对
Jake: Yes, his name is Ancient Greece.
Jake:叫古希腊
Jake: Called Ancient Greece.
Katrina: 因为我本来是
Katrina: Because I originally...
其他人：你觉得是没油了还是打火石
Others: Do you think it's out of fuel or the flint?
其他人：还是没油了
Others: Or out of fuel?
其他人：  应该是没油了没油了
Others: It should be out of fuel, out of fuel.
Jake:哎你线拿下来了
Jake: Hey, you took the wire off.
Lucia: 哇好可爱
Lucia: Wow, so cute.
Tasha: 怎么样
Tasha: How is it?
Jake:挺好天晴挺暖和挺暖和的
Jake: Pretty good, the weather is nice and warm, nice and warm.
Tasha: 拔错吧
Tasha: Wrong plug, right?
Jake:我看看去
Jake: Let me check.
Jake:我是个
Jake: I am a...
Jake:我看看我是个什么东西
Jake: Let me see, what am I?
Shure: 我你现在特潮
Shure: You are really trendy now.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Tasha: 特潮
Tasha: Super trendy.
Shure: 还有白头发
Shure: And you have white hair.
其他人：然后白头发抛了
Others: Then the white hair got thrown out.
其他人： 我他妈头全没了哈哈哈
Others: My whole head is bald now, hahaha.
Shure: 好古奇娜
Shure: Okay, Katrina.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Shure: 太潮了真的
Shure: So trendy, really.
Shure: 你今天就这样
Shure: You are like this today.
Jake:我就我今天就这样
Jake: I am, I am like this today.
Jake:这是一个大勋章是不是
Jake: This is a big medal, right?
Jake:这是这是
Jake: This, this is...
Shure: 这是你可以叫supernova超新星
Shure: You can call it supernova, supernova.
Tasha: 还有只短腿的
Tasha: And a short-legged one.
Jake:哪呢这个
Jake: Where is it?
Tasha: 这呢  谁啊
Tasha: Here it is. Who is it?
Jake:这就是短腿的
Jake: This is the short-legged one.
Jake:哦这长腿
Jake: Oh, this one has long legs.
Shure: 北邮也火了
Shure: BUPT is famous now.
Shure: 什么着火了是吗
Shure: What, something caught fire?
Jake:这个是长腿
Jake: This one has long legs.
Shure: 阳台抽烟把把衣服点着了
Shure: Someone smoked on the balcony and set the clothes on fire.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Jake:这什么地方啊沙河
Jake: What's this place? Shahe?
Tasha: 呵呵呵
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：阳台抽烟
Others: Smoking on the balcony.
Jake:面包大学是什么
Jake: What's Bread University?
Shure: 不知道什么叫面包大学
Shure: I don't know what Bread University is.
Jake:给你运上去
Jake: I'll send it up to you.
Shure: 老学长们都已经不懂这个梗了是吧
Shure: The old seniors don't get this joke, right?
Tasha: 谢谢
Tasha: Thanks.
Jake:确实不懂
Jake: I really don't get it.
Jake:你知道吗
Jake: Do you know?
Shure: 我也不知道
Shure: I don't know either.
Jake:那你们也老学长
Jake: Then you're also an old senior.
Shure: 我也老学长了
Shure: I'm an old senior too.
Jake:不懂沙河的这些梗
Jake: Don't understand these Shahe jokes.
Tasha: 嗯剪刀呢
Tasha: Hmm, where are the scissors?
Shure: 我是一个普通话一甲的主持人
Shure: I'm a first-class Mandarin host.
Jake:哦是吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Jake:你好
Jake: Hello.
Tasha: 你好
Tasha: Hello.
Jake:我我姐今天又又又破防了
Jake: My sister got triggered again today.
Jake:又又又给我们整破防了
Jake: She triggered us again.
Tasha: 怎么了
Tasha: What happened?
Lucia: 我爱爱听
Lucia: I love listening.
Lucia: 爱听一些别人洞房故事
Lucia: Love listening to other people's wedding night stories.
Jake:首首先首先是路上看到一个挖掘机
Jake: First of all, she saw an excavator on the road.
Jake:然后问我开没开过
Jake: Then asked if I had driven one before.
Tasha: 我家有挖机
Tasha: My family has an excavator.
Tasha: 去我家开
Tasha: Come to my house to drive it.
Lucia: 我不光开过还造过
Lucia: Not only have I driven one, but I've also built one.
Jake:你造过嗯
Jake: You've built one? Wow.
Lucia: 我亲手一块一块拼出来的
Lucia: I pieced it together myself, piece by piece.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Tasha: 杨sirm
Tasha: Jake, sir.
Tasha: 等我装饰房间的呢
Tasha: Waiting for me to decorate the room.
Jake:怎么搞what should i do
Jake: How do I do it, what should I do?
Tasha: what should i do
Tasha: What should I do?
Jake:what should i do
Jake: What should I do?
Tasha: 把快递先都拆了
Tasha: First, unpack all the parcels.
Tasha: 然后拿上来
Tasha: Then bring them up.
Tasha: 然后开始装饰
Tasha: Then start decorating.
Jake:好好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Jake:你现在插的是你的线还是我的线
Jake: Are you plugging in your cable or mine?
Tasha: 我现在插的插的是我的生命
Tasha: I'm plugging in my lifeline.
Tasha: 你的生命线
Tasha: Your lifeline.
Jake:我的生命线了
Jake: My lifeline then.
Tasha: 是的我的生命线在楼下
Tasha: Yes, my lifeline is downstairs.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 那你完了
Tasha: Then you're done for.
Jake:古希腊怎么拼
Jake: How do you spell Ancient Greece?
Tasha: 知道这是什么吗
Tasha: Do you know what this is?
Jake:这纸眼睛
Jake: This paper eye.
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one.
Tasha: 你知道这眼睛怎么用吗
Tasha: Do you know how to use this eye?
Jake:贴眼睛上
Jake: Stick it on the eye.
Tasha: 贴在哪都会很有灵魂
Tasha: Stick it anywhere and it will have soul.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:贴眼睛上
Jake: Stick it on the eye.
Tasha: 你把你手机拿出来
Tasha: Take out your phone.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Jake:你这线是谁的线
Jake: Whose cable is this?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 我的呀
Shure: It's mine.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Jake:那这线是谁的线
Jake: Then whose cable is this?
Tasha: 我的
Tasha: Mine.
Jake:那你的线是谁的线
Jake: Then whose cable is yours?
Tasha: 你的
Tasha: Yours.
Jake:那我这根线是谁的线
Jake: Then whose cable is this one?
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Jake:我看看我去
Jake: Let me see, I'm going to check.
Jake:挺可爱我看看你的线是什么线
Jake: So cute, let me see what kind of thread you have.
Jake:你这线是我的线
Jake: Your thread is actually mine.
Tasha: 可爱吧你想要什么
Tasha: Cute, right? What do you want?
Tasha: 都可以你想要几百个
Tasha: Anything, how many hundreds do you want?
Tasha: 哪都可以贴
Tasha: You can stick it anywhere.
Tasha: 贴上就注入了灵魂
Tasha: Once you stick it, it gets a soul.
Tasha: 给你两个大眼睛
Tasha: Here, two big eyes for you.
其他人：这么可爱
Others: So cute.
Tasha: 是的呗
Tasha: Right?
Tasha: 哪都能贴
Tasha: You can stick it anywhere.
Tasha: 贴手机上贴充电器上贴冰红茶上
Tasha: Stick it on your phone, on your charger, on your iced tea.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 知道要剪掉吗
Tasha: You know you need to cut it, right?
Tasha: 哈哈帮我贴
Tasha: Hahaha help me stick it.
其他人：帮我贴
Others: Help me stick it.
Tasha: 帮你贴啊
Tasha: I'll help you stick it.
Tasha: 你想要大眼睛还是小眼睛
Tasha: Do you want big eyes or small eyes?
其他人：这个这个挺好
Others: This one, this one is nice.
其他人：这个大小真好
Others: This size is perfect.
其他人：你是我姐
Others: You're my sister.
其他人：我太喜欢这些小玩意了
Others: I really love these little things.
Tasha: 我也喜欢
Tasha: I love them too.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:哦哦哦这都有啊
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, there's more here.
Jake:这一圈都可以拍
Jake: You can film all around here.
Tasha: 什么然后
Tasha: What then?
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
其他人：这是他原来的
Others: That's his original.
Tasha: 对啊哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Yeah, hahahaha.
Tasha: 他连你下面的都想要
Tasha: He even wants the ones under you.
Jake:这下面的现在应该还能买的到
Jake: The ones below should still be available now.
Jake:对当时我觉得能买到也挺牛逼的
Jake: Yeah, I thought it was pretty cool to get them back then.
Tasha: 要不要给你眼镜上贴两个超小的
Tasha: Do you want to stick two tiny ones on your glasses?
Jake:怎么贴
Jake: How do you stick them?
Jake:我靠这个是比目鱼
Jake: Whoa, this is a flounder.
Jake:这是什么鱼
Jake: What kind of fish is this?
Tasha: 什么比目鱼
Tasha: What flounder?
Jake:掌掌掌两边的鱼是指什么鱼
Jake: The fish with eyes on both sides, what fish is that?
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: I don't know.
其他人：别说手感还挺好
Others: I have to say, it feels pretty good.
Tasha: 现在就给你一个命令
Tasha: Now I'm giving you an order.
Tasha: 把家里所有的能贴上眼镜的
Tasha: Stick glasses on everything in the house.
Tasha: 都注入灵魂
Tasha: Inject soul into all of them.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Tasha: 现在把手上贴两个再在门口
Tasha: Now stick two on your hands and then at the door.
Jake:再等等这边贴两个
Jake: Wait, wait, stick two over here.
Jake:迎接一下客人哈哈
Jake: To greet the guests, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What's this?
Jake:把门上贴两个
Jake: Stick two on the door.
Jake:修硕眼睛上贴两个
Jake: Stick two on Shure's eyes.
Tasha: 这不是我的
Tasha: This isn't mine.
Tasha: 哦这还是我的好
Tasha: Oh, this is mine. Good.
Jake:开玩笑我们走了一路全是梨
Jake: Kidding, we walked a whole way full of pears.
其他人：这个是什么
Others: What's this?
Tasha: 不知道很可爱吧
Tasha: No idea, but it's cute, right?
Tasha: 不知道是什么
Tasha: No idea what it is.
Jake:拿来咱拿去野餐
Jake: Take it, we'll use it for a picnic.
Jake:浴袍床单
Jake: Bathrobe, bed sheets.
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: Don't know.
Tasha: 就是挺好看的
Tasha: It's just pretty nice.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake:这是哪个民族啊
Jake: Which ethnic group is this from?
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: Don't know.
Jake:甜品民族
Jake: Dessert tribe.
Jake:甜品族
Jake:我觉得挺好
Jake: I think it's pretty good.
Jake:这饭就到位了
Jake: This meal is just right.
其他人：这个钟有什么故事啊
Others: What's the story behind this clock?
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: Don't know.
Jake:这钟这么小
Jake: This clock is so small.
Jake:好看反了
Jake: Looks great.
Jake:好看
Tasha: 好看 5号电池派上用场了
Tasha: Looks great. The size 5 battery came in handy.
其他人：还得是你
Others: It's all you.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Jake:还得是你
Jake: It's all you.
Jake:不是一个够的都对不起你
Jake: If one isn't enough, it's unfair to you.
Tasha: 我们屁人就是讲究机缘巧合
Tasha: We folks just believe in serendipity.
Tasha: 这什么好看
Tasha: What's this? It's beautiful.